hey guys cam here now I don't know about
you but when I play games I tend to play
either on my own or with a friend or
sometimes with these lovely chumps but
how about playing in front of 13,000
people well that was the attendance at
the League of Legends season 3 World
Finals held in the famous LA Staples
Center earlier this year and it's sold
out in under an hour
big numbers but perhaps not surprising
when you consider that 27 million people
play League of Legends every day and
that's enough to fill the Staples Center
2076
times in fact League of Legends is
arguably the biggest game in the world
as a result a great context to answer a
question I've been thinking about for
quite a while does having a packed
Stadium watching your every mouse click
and trigger squeeze actually help or
perhaps hinder your gaming performance
so when are rare bouts of pre-planning
at this year's games calm myself and sab
chicken the sights and sounds of the EU
LCS summer playoffs over two and a half
thousand spectators crowded into the
tiered seating of the riot arena with
hundreds waiting outside queueing to get
a glimpse of the action after watching a
really tense and exciting semi-final
between Team Rocket and the alternate
Victor's fnatic I sat down for a chat
with the winning side and also the match
caster to find out how they felt a live
audience could affect their own
performance well the very first time I
should have to play in front of a live
audience it definitely made me worse
because I was very nervous you know now
you have all these people are cheering
for you and also cheering against you if
they're for the other team so you know
okay if you make a mistake you give up a
kill for instance the crowd goes wild
and you know it's against use in that
case I was very very nervous actually
going on stage but after the very first
time I've done it it only helped me
because then you get the feeling as well
like it carries you so if you do get a
good start if you do do something really
good in the game you hear the crowd and
you just take it and you roll with it
but I like to think okay well the good
thing is we're like the cool play
everyone's gonna go crazy so I just
gonna wait for that play even if I don't
do anything half an hour then I do what
could play people's gonna go crazy so it
kind of motivated me to instead of
thinking that they are there I try to
think that they are there for a good
thing you know like they are cheering
not a boon or to watch what I do but to
cheer before your in game you are of
course really nervous about everything
and then when you get into the game I
don't really even notice the crowd I
just try my best to focus on the game
I think nervousness actually helps me in
many ways because it makes me play so
much better than I usually do because I
always think twice about everything I do
I don't really have a tactic actually
it's just sort of the person I am I've
always been playing sports so I've
always learned how to be cold blooded
where you're always in is like hi matter
situations where you just be calm you're
the most calm guy in the team it affects
our performance in a good way because
sometimes is really good when they're
cheering for you especially when you're
losing but at the same time when you do
a good action and they are there like
cheering for you you just want to do
more and then sometimes it leads you to
mistake but I'm not blaming them at all
it's just
sometimes managing our stress or us
being perfect you know so that's what
the pros think but what can science and
psychology tell us everybody meets
social facilitation social facilitation
this is everybody so this describes the
effect that simply having people present
and watching has on an individual's
ability to do a task this has been
studied a lot in a context of both
professional sport as a way of
explaining the increased number of world
records set at major tournaments like
the Olympics and also just general task
performance so what has the research
shown well it seems that by just having
people watch what you're doing it can
actually make you better at a task but
not always simply depends on the nature
of the task in question crucially if the
person is performing either a simple
task or one that's very well practiced
then the effect of having an audience
watching is usually positive conversely
performance at a tricky or completely
new task with an audience of spectators
looking on can actually worsen
performance a psychologist Robert Zonk
argued the presence of others serves as
a source of arousal and heightened
arousal increases the likelihood of
individuals to perform well at a learned
task this just means that a person's
drive to do a thing is higher if the
task is well practiced or simple whereas
it's lower for more complex or less
practiced tasks this is not the only
theory attempting to explain the effects
of social facilitation though Nicholas
Cottrell argues that it's not so much
the presence of the people that matters
per se but it's more to do with their
apprehension of being evaluated by those
watching now we know that approval
disapproval and her overall self esteem
are often dependent on others opinions
and evaluations so it's fast a reason
that the presence of others could
increase our drive to perform based on
anxiety over the impending evaluation
this appeals to me as it explains her
confidence and one's abilities could be
a huge dictator of whether or not a
crowd helps a person or form it's kind
of like an exam situation
confident then you don't fear the exam
so much and in fact it can really Drive
you to excel however if you're less
confident your abilities then the
pressure of the evaluation can really
get you and diminish your performance so
all this research is pretty damn
interesting but one thing it doesn't
help us understand is the impact of an
online audience and for high stakes
League of Legends matches these numbers
can be insane
in fact our pals at fnatic set a record
for the most single viewed match an ESL
history at the ESL's Intel Extreme
Masters earlier this year when 511
thousand viewers tuned in concurrently
on Twitch to see the action unfold so
could this online audience also be
having some impact on the players well
it's hard to say really as there's been
no research directly carried out on the
impact of remote audiences on a player
so I put the question to the fnatic guys
to get their insight either semis there
is think a 100k won 1 million what
really matters is that people you see in
front of you you know because I think
everyone counts like the stream as one
people one person you have a camera on
you but you don't even think about that
you think the cameras are there too so
it's tough for the people in the place
so for me I really never thought about
it it was never a problem
I never thought if it was 100 K or 300 K
I never thought it because I don't even
know until the game is over anyway so so
first of all when you do play and with
all the online viewers you don't even
care because you don't even think about
the fact it's being streamed you don't
think about the fact you have all these
people online watching that's where the
live crowd really kicks in because now
you see these people in real life and
you see them reacting to what's going on
and that's where you get effective are
so how much do you think a crowd can
affect a gamers performance and do you
agree with our pros assessment of things
let me know in the comments and remember
if you want to suggest a reality check
topic then the best way to do that is to
tweet directly at me at cam Fras Rob ok
guys thanks for watching see you next
week